hey accidents happen but if you're in a
movie Sometimes accidents can turn out
to be amazing in fact some of the most
memorable moments in cinema were
actually the result of mistakes that the
filmmakers decided were too good to
leave out of the finished movie Alfred
Hitchcock coined the term McGuffin to
describe important objects upon which
the plot of a movie revolves like the
briefcase in Pulp Fiction or the
Infinity Stones in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as any comic fan will tell you
the Infinity Stones are incredibly
important and Powerful which is why it's
so funny when Chris Pratt is Star-Lord
just straight up drops one
what you brought
[Music]
it looks totally scripted but according
to the DVD commentary that was an actual
moment of clumsiness from Pratt but the
moment works so director James Gunn left
it in as wall looms and the loss of
Rohan seems imminent ayowen stares off
into the distance as the camera reveals
a wide Scenic shot as she does a
flagpole whips in the wind and then
perfectly expressing the mood of
uncertainty and destruction to come the
flag rips off the pole and flies away
the metaphor was not only beautifully
apt but it was also totally accidental
director Peter Jackson didn't plan for
this it was just really windy on that
day of shooting this movie made Anne
Hathaway a star and the DVD has become a
slumber party classic for little kids
it's a classic
ugly duckling story of a girl named Mia
who finds out she's The Heir Apparent to
a small European Kingdom but she's so
very awkward you see falling down all
the time as she learns how to carry
herself with the Grayson boys befitting
a royal at one point Mia is dancing on
some bleachers in the rain at a private
school with a best friend when she takes
a pretty nasty tumble to look just right
[Laughter]
that's no stunt woman and that wasn't
supposed to happen I thought we really
did slip falling hard but it fit in so
well with the character's awkwardness
that it was kept in the finished film
the idea was simple Bond girl rides a
horse along the beach and Daniel Craig
swims up to her but as he floated up the
actor ran into a sand Bank giving him no
choice but to quickly stand up on his
feet and stomp out of the water suddenly
bond is standing there muscled up body
on display along with some very
revealing swim trunks Casino Royale was
a reboot of the bond series so most fans
assumed this was an homage to the
classic scene from the first Bond film
Dr no where Ursula Andrus emerges from
the ocean but it was actually just a
lucky accident
Indiana Jones wasn't the only Raider of
the Lost Ark in uh Raiders of the Lost
Ark there was also evil French
archaeologist Renee bellock who suffers
a doubly horrible fate not only does his
head explode
but he also needs a fly well okay not
exactly during a close-up of actor Paul
Freeman a fly appears to crawl right
down belock's throat Freeman later
revealed that the insect actually flew
away after crawling around his lip for a
moment but some judicious editing after
the fact made it look like the
cold-blooded bellock just ate the fly
instead the police lineup scene early in
the movie is crucial to the plot of The
Usual Suspects it's where all the
criminal main characters meet to arrange
a Big Heist as each character steps
forward to read the line police told
them to read none of them can contain
their laughter perfectly setting up the
dynamic between the characters as well
as their Collective disregard for the
cops
but the Laughing wasn't in the script
and it wasn't a directorial note no the
cast of The Usual Suspects couldn't stop
laughing because actor Benicio del Toro
couldn't stop farting co-star Kevin
Pollock says he farted on like 12 tags
in a row director Brian Singer got so
mad with the cast's inability to focus
that he yelled at them which probably
only made them laugh harder speaking of
farts Rain Man is that rare film that
won the Oscar for Best Picture it also
included one of the most memorable fart
scenes in movie history Brothers Raymond
and Charlie are in a phone booth
together and Raymond passes gas
did you fart right how can you stand
that I don't mind that was real and
accidental Stars Dustin Hoffman and Tom
Cruise both managed to stay completely
in character setting up a classic moment
in cinematic fart history one of
Django's Chief Ames in this 2012 Western
is to free his wife from the clutches of
terrifyingly crazed slave owner Calvin
candy the meeting between Jamie Foxx's
Django and Leonardo DiCaprio's Calvin is
extremely tense and for dramatic effect
DiCaprio slams his hand on a table and
right onto a glass
table top if you lift those
both fails that start off DiCaprio
didn't stop at all during the take even
though he just seriously lacerated his
hand nonchalantly picking out the pieces
of glass and even lighting a cigarette
Daryl Hannah took home a souvenir from
the set of blade runner in the form of a
scar on her arm and the take in which
she injured it making its way into the
movie while playing a replicant named
Priss Hannah ran from William
sanderson's genetic designer JF
Sebastian and slipped onto the wet
pavement
[Music]
hey breaking the window wasn't planned
but Hannah finished filming the scene
preserving what ended up being a fairly
Serious injury for posterity for her
role as the manipulative Outlaw Daisy
and Quentin Tarantino's the hateful
eight Jennifer Jason Lee had to know how
to play a little guitar she learned on a
vintage 19th century Martin on loan to
the production from The Martin guitar
Museum in one scene Lee's co-star Kurt
Russell was supposed to yank the
instrument out of her hands and smash it
to Smithereens but the cameras were
supposed to cut first so it could be
swapped out for an ordinary guitar
music time's over
but the cut didn't come and Russell
unknowingly destroyed the antique Martin
valued at forty thousand dollars so
Lee's reaction is the real thing
James Cameron's 1994 spy comedy contains
some of the biggest and most expensive
sequences in movie history but the one
scene from True Lies everybody remembers
two decades later is Jamie Lee Curtis's
striptease her character Helen takes off
her clothes for a man she believes to be
an arms dealer but is actually her
husband Harry played by Arnold
Schwarzenegger Curtis's sexy moment is
interrupted briefly when she loses her
balance
[Music]
it's a perfect Pratt fall with
impeccable comic timing but it wasn't in
Cameron's script Curtis didn't want to
do the scene the way it was scripted
which called for her to get completely
naked and filmed in silhouette Cameron
agreed to her changes and they worked
out the choreography without
Schwarzenegger's knowledge so that's a
genuine reaction from Schwarzenegger who
thought the fall would ultimately just
end up as a blooper the 1969 low budget
classic Midnight Cowboy features one of
the most famous unscripted lines in
movie history as Dustin Hoffman's retso
Rizzo and Jon Voight's Joe Buck are
walking across a very busy and very real
Manhattan Street having a conversation a
cab nearly hits Hoffman
[Music]
Hoffman's response was so perfectly in
character that director John Schlesinger
kept it in the film which went on to win
best picture at the Academy Awards it's
a scene originally meant the service
just a transition allowing Woody Allen's
proud New Yorker character Alvey and his
girlfriend Annie to mention they're
taking a trip to Los Angeles but has
become a classic bit of physical comedy
thanks to an unplanned moment a stash of
cocaine said to be worth two thousand
dollars an ounce is passed around at a
party eventually arriving at Alvey
thank you
Allen says it was a complete unplanned
accident but test screen audiences
laughed uproariously at it so Alan also
the director of the movie kept it in